Welcome everybody to another Zoom call
Just a reminder to
Post your questions on the members page
And you'll see any new announcements on the members page home page as well
If during the Zoom call if you have any questions just post it in the chat and we'll get at them
But let's get to the questions that were sent in first
First question my husband is suddenly having some weezy again
And I'm wondering if a nebulizer and hydrogen
Proxide will be helpful
I read that it may not be a good idea with a collapse lung as you know
He had a slight collapse or is there something else that you would recommend?
He is already taking mullin
So mullin is a great thing to help clear congestion in a lung
Um, typically weezy can be caused from a constrictor of the bronchials
Or the bronchiali the smaller bronchials
Um, and um, that can be due to an allergy weezy is common asthma type symptoms
Um, typically you won't get a weezy so much with a collapse lung or pneumonia
But uh, mullin can still be a good thing
Uh, cordiseps can be good
Anacetyl cysteine can be good to help clear the lung
Um, and certainly nebulizing with hydrogen peroxide and that
Hydrogen peroxide recipe is on the home page of the member site
Trying all those things
Next question. I see a lot of videos on rife like machines lately
They make some crazy claims. What do you think? Excuse me
So there's a lot of videos um if you're watching youtube if you're watching instagram if you're watching tiktok
If you're watching facebook
You're watching any of the social media sites. There's a lot of alternative help
Influencers that have flooded the market
Um talking about rife machines talking about different supplements talking about different cures for this disease that disease
Including cancer can't tell you how many calls that we had getting where people are asking questions
Thinking oh, I can't wait till the med bed comes out because that could grow limbs
There's so many false and outrageous claims about things
It is just I tell you from from our perspective as a clinic that we're trying to do things honestly
And not make claims that are that are
unethical it immoral
Uh, you know, I don't know how people can do these things and still have a conscience
But then you're reminded that it's the bible is very clear that in the last days people's consciousness will be seared
And they'll they will just lie through their teeth to do anything Jesus
You know called the Pharisees the synagogue of Satan that they'll they do is
Speak lies because lying is their native language
So it is just it is so hard
Never before in my practice, of course, I'm an old guy and I've been doing this for 40 years
But never before have I seen so many people come
Thinking that if they just do xyz, they're going to be cured of their disease whether it be cancer or some autoimmune disease
Because they saw a tiktok video or because they saw a instagram video
Um, it's just so sad how
Many people are bad-boozled by just easy lies
So I would caution everybody to be careful of what you see out there
I too have seen a bunch of videos on rife machines and you click on the website because I'm you know a
You know
Kind of a junkie for what is another
Therapy going to do to help my patients get better
So I look into it and boy they have some
Very classy ads. They've spent a fortune on their fancy dancing website and paid
Companies to make wonderful AI
You know videos that
That make their machine look like it could grow limbs
Matter of fact that is one of the comments that is on
The medbed that was so big in you know, it's all first of you know when it came out several years ago
Um literally people were making claims that it could literally grow limbs back and and this is a rife machine. It's just
I just and the FDA came after them. I just
This is so bad because these kind of false claims and things and these videos that show
Just miraculous healing. I'm not saying that people aren't miraculously healed
I'm saying that the only way you are healed is miraculous healing
But to say that some tool is going to miraculously heal everybody that uses it whether you have
All sorts of colitis or you have prostate cancer
Is just alive from the pit of hell and I get these things hurt
Ultimately hurt alternative practitioners because um
You know, then the FDA has grounds to literally shut everybody down
Because these these claims are out there that are such false claims
So I'd caution you against those things these companies are flyby net companies
The FDA is going to shut them down. They're going to be gone
um and
They they can say whatever they want because they're not practitioners. So they don't have
You know, boards looking after what they say and what they claim
I would caution you against and I've said this multiple times caution you and against
these
natural alternative
practitioners that have gotten into the space simply because they want to get you know
500,000 followers so that they can end up making money off their videos and that they make claims and say things on the videos
Full of half truths and um and they just get shares and likes and
and comments and and they make money doing that and that's that is what they do and it's just
It's frustrating from my point of view quite honestly. It makes me want to not do this anymore. So
um, I
Don't be fooled by the lies that are out there
That's what I can best make
Uh, comment about a question like that
Next question if we do everything right to help heal our cancer. Why does it always work
Well, that's kind of keeping it in the same question
We could do everything right for any type of situation and what we think is right
Is you know, let's say we okay, we do some toxicity tests
We find out we're have a bunch of toxins and so we do everything right to help ourselves detox
We start eating correctly and we start taking supplements to detox and we start doing detox type therapies and coffee
Enemies and doing sodas and we do everything right
And we might run that toxicity test again in six months or a year
It still shows a lot of toxins what is going on it can be extremely frustrating
We live in a toxic world. We live in a poison world
There's a good documentary that keeps coming up on my feet that I want to watch it something about forever
And forever or something and it's a it's about the forever chemicals
And I'll like all I've seen I haven't watched the documentary, but I've just seen
A short little clip about it and it talks about how
3M right here in Minnesota has made these forever chemicals
And now in the clip the scientists would say it is in every human's bloodstream on the planet
That's a scary thing
We have literally we as a human race have literally poisoned the planet. It's amazing that we're all still alive
um
So we can do everything quote unquote right which is again
All the things that we know to do and it's we still don't maintain or obtain health
um
Ultimately, we have to have this or I push everybody back to you have to have a faith in Jesus Christ that he is
Ultimately your savior and he is ultimately responsible for your healing
And yes, you are responsible to do everything that you know to be right
But then you have to fall into the hands of your savior and trust him for the difference
Because we can do everything that we know to be right and still fail in our endeavor to be healthy
We also have to caution ourselves to not have that become an idol in our life that we have health
But it be our responsibility to stay healthy and then um leaving the results to God
Keep it from being an idol so that we don't get frustrated when we don't get what we want
Next question
Is there a point when taking uh HCl
And digestive enzymes that you would say one could be taking too much
Oh for sure not so much digestive enzymes you can't really overdose digestive enzymes
The more you take you you know you'll
Initially digestive enzymes that you take with your food you're going to use your body's going to use to help digest that food
If you take too many digestive enzymes with your meal you could have some loose stools maybe
But you will absorb some of those that you don't need in your digestive tract. That's a whole idea of
enzyme therapy for cancer
You're taking very very very high dose digestive enzymes
Away from food on an empty stomach and you're absorbing them
And the hope that they'll circulate and then they'll help break down the way slayer around the cancer
So you can't really owe the digestive enzymes, but you certainly can owe the
hydrochloric acid
So hydrochloric acid is taken to supplement the lack of hydrochloric acid production in your stomach
and
Even a small amount can be too much when you start because if you have a lack of hydrochloric acid in your stomach
You could get a build up an overgrowth of Hpilori and then destruction of the stomach wall and a small little ulcer
Doesn't have to be a screaming bleeding ulcer
But you could have a small little ulcer and then you take HCl with digestive enzymes
Because you hear those are good for you or Dr. Cutters told you to
And boy they cause a lot of pain when I take them even when I take one it just kills my stomach
Well, that means you probably have an ulcer you got to back off of that
You have to go on like the GI soothe product
A product that will be healing to the gut
That has deglycerized licorice and slippery elm and some other herbs in it that will heal that stomach wall
For a sore period of time then you could either go back on the HCl or try a little bit
Later acid which would be acetic acid in like apple cider vinegar
But that's saying that the HCl doesn't cause your stomach to be
I have issues but I just want the best digestion
So what would be too much for me?
Well, you could titrate up in your HCl and digestive enzymes and compound product
Until you do get a little tummy aches with I've had people go up to 678 per meal
And typically you do not want to stay on that type of high dosage
And then when they feel like they're starting to get better digestion
They'll titrate down to 65432 with each meal
And you play with your dosage like that
Certainly you need more if you're dependent on what you eat
So I know for most people it's they're going to eat a lot of meat
Let's say they're going to eat a steak
That is not as pre-digested as hamburger
Let's say that you're you might feel better
Less bloated ham better digestion if you took maybe two or three of them
But if you're eating just a smoothie you might take none
Or if you're eating some some a smaller meal with less
Difficult to digest food
Then you'd maybe only take one so you learn to play with your dosage
But yes, you can take too much HCl
Next question
My oncologist said that it doesn't matter what a cancer patient eats
How could they still be so ignorant?
Um yeah, I would agree that that is ignorance and I don't mean that in a negative way
But it's just lack of knowledge
I don't understand how anybody
At this point in history
With the amount of knowledge that is available at your fingertips
That you can still think that your diet doesn't have anything to do with your health
Because certainly somebody with the more serious disease
Their diet would have more to do with your health than somebody who is let's say
Feeling great has no symptoms doesn't have any weight issues has no high blood pressure has perfect blood work
Then I guess I could understand a doctor saying well don't worry about what you eat because you're doing real well
But when someone has a health issue to say your diet doesn't do anything
Beat anything cause anything I
I don't have an answer for this. I don't know how someone could be that foolish
I just don't know how you're
Maybe because you're so invested in a drug-based system
that you you can't
Invest yourself enough to have a rational thought
I don't know if you consult a psychologist with that question, I guess
next question
I'm feeling well and started to finally put some weight back on naturally
I'd considered a very short fast to help reset my cells
I looked at the prologue therapy fast the prologue fast is a fine day
Fasting mimicking diet
But was wondering if maybe just a simple two-day water juice tea fast might be as effective
I've done a two-day fast I've never done a two-day fast only timed fasted
Of 13 hours
What do you think might be the best thing for me? I did not want to lose weight
So I would you know
From a technical standpoint, I never recommend to fast over 24 hours for cancer patients can increase
IGF-1 levels and that can
Have some ill effects on a cancer patient. So I would not do it two-day fast
The prologue therapy five-day fasting mimicking diet is a five-day
specific meals that come with that with that diet comes all pre-packaged
That's something you could choose to do or just do
24 hour fast maximum I would do any more than that
certainly just sticking to a
Timer-stricted eating where maybe you choose to do for two or three days straight where you only have an eat window
let's say
between five and seven pm
And then the next day between five and seven pm and the next day between five and seven pm
Therefore, you're only doing a 22 hour fast three days in a row
That would be better than doing a two-day fast in my opinion
Question from the chat. I've struggled with ear infections for my whole life
from seasonal allergies to poor you station tube drainage
Since I've been an adult, I've mostly been able to keep them under control naturally
However lately I've been struggling with what I think is a fungal ear infection
I've been doing the right programs for ear infection and ear conditions with which lists
Um, ear fungus and swimmers ear any other suggestions for this
Um, let me pull up a
Picture here because if I put um
Let's put it over here and then let's put it on here
So
That is your ear. So this is your outer ear ear obviously
You got this is fat layer mode here. This is your
external ear canal
This here is your middle ear. I hope you can see by cursor
And the greed here is your inner
Uh
Part of your inner ear which is this is called your used station tube. So your station tube is a soft
vessel like tube. So it's like a vein
Um, except it doesn't like veins have um
Evalves in it the station two doesn't have valves, but this will drain
This drains down to down here, which is your back of your throat
So on the back of your throat
Was where your used station tube drains and the purpose of the used station tube is to drain the middle ear
So this part of the middle ear if you have an infection
You'll have fluid build up in that and your used station tube is to drain it now part of the reason why
Um, you have fluid build up in the middle ear is that when you have an infection the inflammation
Uh can block the used station tube or one could say part of the reason why they have an infection is they have a
Blocked used station tube
Therefore fluid builds up and you can get an infection
So what came first the chicken or the egg it doesn't make any difference
So what a doctor looks in your ear with an otoscope
They'll see the ear drum here
Bolged outward bulged externally and typically it could be discolored as well
So normally when you look at the ear drum you have a nice flat or actually
Concave ear drum with what's called this code of light
Um, which it looks like a pearly white um, that's a normal looking ear drum
Uh, if you have a middle ear infection it will be bulged out many times. It'll be more purpley
Uh, even red discolored, but you'll have this bulge of the ear drum
Now the idea with children and putting tubes in the ear is they're literally going and putting a teeny little
Three millimeter tube. They're cutting a little hole in the drum putting a tube in there
And that tube that drains the middle ear
The idea makes a lot of sense because you got an infection in the middle ear
It's pushing that drum out and that's what causes pain is that drum being pushed out
So the kids got an ear pain is ear hurt so much and the drum is being pushed out because of a blockage in the use station tube
Now there's things that you can do to help
Remove that blockage with the use in the use station tube the rife will help that
Um, well help get flow you can do the lymph program lymph congestion program on your rife putting it right up by your ear
There is another physical technique
I wish I could show you um, but if you put your finger in your mouth on the roof of your mouth
And followed your finger all the way back
You would elicit the gag reflex because you'll cause yourself to gag
But there is if you went to one side of the other let's say let's say it was my right ear that was causing the issues
I had a right ear infection
And if I looked in with an autoscope I'd have a bulgeed externally bulgeed
um
Ear drum
So there's obviously fluid in there. There's obviously blockage of that use station tube
There's not getting the drain edge down to the back of the throat because that's what the use station tube drains right to the back of the throat
Now you could physically put your mouth on the roof
Put your finger on the roof of your mouth follow it all the way back and then follow it back to one side or the other
No, you will probably elicit the gag reflex so you have to do this really quick
And you will there's there's a little
A little indentation there
Where the use you station tube comes out. It's called the fossa of rosemieler
um
So if you could get your finger back to that fossa of rosemieler and just wiggle your finger really quick
And then pull your finger out before you throw up
You could
It would stimulate this use station tube and possibly stimulate it to open up
I've done this
Hundreds of times a little kids and adults when I had a physical practice
and that is
stimulating
the
Where the use station to exits
From the middle ear and drains from the middle ear back to the faucet of rosemieler
Now the problem is you have to go really quick because you will elicit a gag reflex
That's hard to do that on a kid because they'll bite your finger and blow them up
But in adults you can get back there and
tickle that and rub that to open that up
You can do other things to try to open your use station tube. You know you've tried to
You know plug your nose and blow really hard
There's all sorts of different things that you can do all you're doing with plugging your nose and blowing really hard or
Swallowed or gargling with saltwater. You're trying to stimulate that area the faucet of rosemieler where
Their use station tube is is exited and
Drainied the middle ear so by stimulating it you hope to have a reflex that opens that up
Um
That's what I would suggest. So doing all those things trying to gargle with saltwater
Um, you could gargle with an alcohol or something that could stimulate that
And you know trying to open that up
So that is a middle ear infection. That's very very carbon
Um, could you have a fungus in the middle ear?
Maybe what is it usually
Did you know in all the studies that are out there like literally 98% of the time it's viral
So think of also on the right writing the viral complex program that may help
Now don't confuse that and it's completely different than having an external ear infection
That's it
Infection in the canal here and people could have very odd shaped canals because the bones their bones are different so your canal
Is is takes the shape of the boat if you have an extra large mastoid here
That could cause a very odd shaped canal and that could cause a poolade
So that a person has a little
kind of indentation and poolade down here of the external canal and they're very prone to infections of the external canal. Now
Infections the external canal are different
Totally different. It's on the external side of the ear drum and that is typically called swimmers ear because you get water in there
And some people are more prone to even going to take it a shower because of that odd shaped canal
They could have more issues with the external canal
Infections. That's a different issue. You're not really happy to do anything with your station tube with that because
The drum seals the external canal from the middle ear
Um, if you have a tear in the drum you'll have loss of hearing for a paratype of the drum will heal
Um, but if you have a really bad middle ear infection the drum could actually tear
Uh, it hurt like the dickens, but then it does give you relief because the fluid drains out the
Out the canal external canal
But then it could take a while to heal and it could heal with a scar and you could have hearing issues
You don't want to have to do that if it all possible. So if you have an external canal issue then putting garlic oil and
And olive oil coconut oil can be helpful any oil can help loosen things up and help with any infection in there
Even if you have a middle ear infection using garlic oil there is a herb farm brand of garlic
Oil that's made for the ear. It's external garlic oil. It's garlic and olive oil
I think that you could put it there and some garlic can
absorb through that um
Topetic membrane membrane the ear drum and get into there to help fight infection
And then think of taking antivirals like garlic oil and and all of leaf extractor things like that could be helpful as well
Okay, next question
The fluid sensitivity test measured a protein and coffee so I'm switching to something else research showed
There
Yourma mate has the most caffeine
Uh any reason not to use that for an enema
Uh, no, no, yeah, I don't think I've ever had anybody say they were going to use that product
So let me the hawkose. Yeah, I don't think there's any problem with the with using that
Next question for the chat if your numbers for your AST, ALT and GGT are good does that mean the liver is detoxed at a good shape
Um, no, it doesn't
Um, remember your blood tests just give you clues
And they really give you clues of healthy function or dysfunction
And it can take a lot of
Disfunction before those numbers get out of balance
So I would never say your blood all looks good your liver numbers look good
That means your liver is all detoxed
Your liver is constantly detoxifying if you're not detoxifying
You are toxified and you're getting sicker
So
Even if a person is a slow detoxifier let's say their liver is not doing
It's not let's say their liver is damaged and it's only functioning at
You know 35% of its function you can still have normal AST and ALT and GGT
Your liver is just only going to function at 35% of its functions so you're
Your your the toxins that are circuited your blood are going to be deposited in your extra cellular spaces and probably be stored in
Extracellular fact cells and other cells
You're you know your liver can store toxins
Um, and if your liver is you know
damaged you can't have elevated AST, ALT, alkaline phosphatase, etc
But you know your liver can be functioning far less than it should and you could be very toxic in those numbers to be normal
So I wouldn't say that the liver is detoxed and in good shape
Just because I have good numbers. We don't know all of that. We don't know that for sure
Next question. Is it still your recommendation to not pause a rife program if not finished?
I'd have a difficulty finishing my cancer program since I start
by night
With programs to help with digestion and then start the cancer program around 2 a.m
thus not
Finished by 8 a.m
I tried to complete the virus and digestion programs during the day, but not doing well managing the times
Well, I would say it totally depends on where you're at with your cancer
So if a person's cancer is in a relative state of remission
Then you know you're getting still getting six hours
You know at what the time you told me of cancer programming, which is typically plenty
so um
If your if your cancer is growing and you're not doing well
I would you know
Then try to get that then maybe pausing it if this is the scenario and try to get it in the morning would be
the best thing to do
Silver could help ear problems. I think you're saying colloidal silver
um colloidal silver used
externally in the external canal hydrogen peroxide
Can be good to kill an infection in the external canal. Yeah, those are those are good suggestions as well
You got to make sure you don't use anything in the external canal if you have a ruptured ear drum
That is the rule of thumb you do not want anything
Getting in to a rub through a damaged ear drum
So if you have a child with tubes in their ear you do not use
colloidal silver or
Hydroproxide or garlic oil or anything like that
Um or if you know you have a ruptured ear drum and you don't do any of those things either
But if you know your drums intact um then doing the kind of
Only if you have an external ear problem that you could do any of those things
Any other questions?
Can you hear me? Yes
I'm having um I don't think I can type that enough so I thought I'd chime in
I'm having blood work done in a few days lab
And I wanted to send in a cheek swab for you to recess
For some supplements and dosages and things like that now
And I wanted to do that sooner rather than later
But I I have some walnut puncture that I've made that's not going to be done for another month or so
for parasites
um
Could I if I send that along
Later with another cheek swab just to have that tested for dosing for me
Would that still be another hundred and fifty dollars?
No, you could do that you could just sell that later that's fine
Okay
All right, that was it. Thank you. Yeah, make sure you send your blood work the your results to me when you get those two
Oh, yeah, I'll always do for real
Oh, okay, we had somebody just enter and we're just about all done
So we did answer your question
Here
Any other questions before we say good and do all right thanks for being on tonight
And we'll see everybody next week
Have a blessed week